(air whooshing)
(phone ringing)
- [Caller] What's up man?
- [Gary] What's up man?
- [Caller] Hey man, you
know it's crazy dude,
you just met Nathan McMasters,
actually he's a close
friend of mine, yesterday.
- Life is crazy.
- [Caller] Yes.
I know you want me to be quick.
Just how to fight through the bullshit
and just be successful every day.
- Okay, so let's define your bullshit.
Like, what's your bullshit?
Parents, work, boss, failed
businesses, your own head?
What's your bullshit?
- [Caller] My bullshit right now man,
I'm just trying to finish my GED
and get into the army right now.
- Okay, so is that a process?
Like that doesn't sound like bullshit,
that sounds like something
in front of you that,
what, you don't like it?
Like you just hate school the way I did,
and so just even getting the
GED is a pain in the ass,
but once you get done
with it you're pumped
'cause then it gets you into the army,
'cause then you're able to get
what you want from the army?
- [Caller] Yeah cause I mean,
my plan is I try to do a
two-year enlistment with the army
and then I'll try to use my GI Bill
to pay for acting school.
Well that's the end-all goal
is to try to get into acting some way.
- So this is where
strategy really matters.
My question is for some reason,
and normally society and parents,
you've decided acting
school is the best way
for you to become an actor
in a world where many actors become actors
without going to acting school.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- Like my question is,
instead of getting a GED
and going to the army
and then going to acting school
and spending the four-and-a-half years
before you even get in at bat,
what about making skits
on Instagram and YouTube
with your homies,
or just going to LA and
just hanging around actors
and making skits to then get
discovered to become an actor?
- [Caller] Yes.
- Let's talk about it.
Let's talk about it.
This is why I decided to
take these seven minutes,
like, I'm here with you
brother, this is me and you,
so like, have you put school on a pedestal
as the gateway to become an actor?
Because so many people in 2019
don't go to acting school
to become an actor,
and I'm like, "Fuck, he's GEDing it,
"to fucking get into the army."
Army's no fucking joke.
You gotta do the army,
then that helps you pay for acting school.
I mean we're talking about
four-and-a-half years
before you even get in at bat.
And as I'm on live my man hammy_tv, right,
is leaving a comment, and he goes,
"You'll get that gig having
millions on social media
"more than acting school."
Now he's talented,
and him and his fiance are
making really great videos,
"sexually"-laced,
but like appropriate for Instagram,
but just you know,
PG, PG, not 13, like rated R,
or something, but nonetheless,
this is a very important question.
Why school to become an
actor, in your brain?
Answer that for me.
- [Caller] Because I just feel like
that's kinda just like acting school,
like you go to school,
to high school, to college,
I feel like that's just
kinda the route that works.
I feel like that's kinda
what I've been taught
and seen in front of me,
is how that works.
- And when I spit the concept
of Instagram and YouTube,
and just going to LA and being a waiter,
and networking with
people that make content,
and then if you've got
the talent, you've got it,
and you get discovered.
Does that sound like an alternative?
Does that sound crazy?
Does that sound like a lottery ticket?
Like how does that sound?
- [Caller] See like to me that just sounds
like something I could get immersed in.
I don't know like,
that doesn't sound--
- Talk.
- [Caller] Rushed at all to me.
That sounds maybe actually how
you're supposed to do it now,
more so than 10, 15 years ago.
That sounds like something
that is what exactly happens now.
You know?
- So, what makes you then not want to?
Are you a family of military
and you wanna do the army thing?
Are you doing the army thing
'cause you don't wanna go
in debt in acting school?
Like talk to me.
- [Caller] Yes sir.
Yeah it's kinda like that.
I mean, my grandpa was a marine,
my dad was in the army.
My freshman and sophomore,
well I kinda rediscovered myself
my freshman and sophomore
year high school.
I was kinda like a jock,
and I kinda went life about that way.
I played basketball, football,
and then once my grades started slipping,
and I couldn't play sports no more,
I was like viewed different,
and I could just see how people change,
just how quick stuff can change for you,
and that kinda put me through,
not like a deep depression,
but, as I've grown up,
I've seen how kinda stupid maybe I've been
to allow myself to be at such
a low point because of that--
- You're not stupid, you're just a human.
Feelings are feelings.
You valued yourself based
on other people's opinions
about you.
And when you weren't an athlete,
people's opinions about you changed.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- Now my biggest question.
Who's opinions do you value?
- [Caller] Um.
- For real.
Like if you're here,
Like, think about the math
around us ever having
this phone call, it's low.
So let's be truthful here, straight up.
Who's opinions do you value?
- [Caller] I would probably
say I value only a few people,
you know, just like--
- Talk. Who?
- [Caller] My Family--
- Who?
- [Caller] My girlfriend--
- Who in your family?
Your girlfriend.
Who?
- [Caller] My father,
my mom, my grandfather,
my girlfriend, Ashley--
- Awesome.
So let's break it down.
I would assume based on
what you just told me
that your father and grandfather
think it's a good idea
for you to go the army?
- [Caller] Yes.
- My biggest question
is, do you think that?
- [Caller] Um.
- Or do you think that
because they think that?
- [Caller] Well, I mean,
as just like a foundation aspect of it.
I believe it will be, but--
- Do you think you can get
that foundation somewhere else?
- [Caller] I mean, yes I do.
I believe I can--
- Where?
- [Caller] Well maybe just like you said,
just keep cracking at it,
and maybe find myself in
LA or something like that.
Doing something,
maybe working in some
minimum-wage job or whatever--
- Let's talk about it.
Do you think that your parent,
your father and grandfather, specifically,
would be devastated if you were like,
"Listen, change of plans.
"I wanna be an actor,
"and what I think is now
the right way to do that
"is to just go to LA
"and make content on YouTube and Instagram
"and give myself two years minimum wage,
"living humbly as fuck,
but living out my dream,
"to even see if I've got it"?
- [Caller] No, I don't
think they would view it
as a, you know what I'm saying.
I think they would be,
what they would want, more so,
is just me to be safe and
be able to pay my bills.
I don't think it would be something
to where they're extremely disappointed.
- Well it sounds like
you have a great
grandfather and father then.
- [Caller] Yeah.
I mean obviously,
they would probably rather me
go into the army--
- Sure,
rather, versus be devastated,
are two very different things.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- My man, there are so
many ways to fucking do it.
- [Caller] Yes, I know.
- I ran a liquor store for 11 years.
- [Caller] Really?
11 years?
- 11 years.
My path to Instagram
and YouTube subscribers
does not look like most (laughs).
- [Caller] Yeah.
- If you wanna be an actor,
if you're asking one man's point of view,
and I can be 100% wrong.
The thought that GED to army,
to acting school,
feels less right than
going to Los Angeles,
working at Fatburger,
and DMing every single
influencer that makes content
for them to have you in their skits.
- [Caller] Yeah.
Well that sounds good to me man, you know.
It's just all about the...
I don't know, I think it's the
way I think too, sometimes--
- Of course, bro, bro,
everything's about the way you think.
This whole game is the way you think.
The world's about how you think.
Perspective is the fucking jam,
like seeing shit in your head is the life.
It's the difference between
happiness and sadness.
success and failure.
Everything's about how you think,
that's why I'm fucking sitting
here on the phone with you
eight minutes and 40 seconds right now.
To give you a seed, to think
about a different maybe.
- [Caller] Yeah.
I mean that's just what I was like.
Like where do I start?
Even how to get over there?
I don't know nobody
over there--
- Take a fucking bus.
- [Caller] Yeah.
Well I live in North Carolina--
- Take a bus.
Take a train, drive,
hitchhike, or take a plane.
You've got some dumb shit in your closet.
Sell it on eBay and buy a plane ticket.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- Go on Craigslist and find a roommate.
- [Caller] Yeah, I know it's possible.
- Of course it's possible,
millions of people do it.
The question is, are you hungry enough,
and willing to fucking
eat shit, or are you soft?
- [Caller] I believe I'm willing to do it,
'cause following you I
hear that, "eat shit,"
and I feel like people that,
unless maybe they've got a
stroke of just complete luck,
they've at least had to
eat shit a little bit--
- Everybody, my man, every
single person that's made it,
they made it, they ate
shit and did the work.
There's people that inherited money,
there's people that have won the lottery.
Let's stop thinking about those people.
Everybody spends all their time
thinking about those people.
Those people are enigmas,
they're anomalies, they're the .00001%.
They have nothing to do with you.
- [Caller] Yeah--
- The 99.999 that made something
of themselves, ate shit.
They put in the work.
- [Caller] You're right.
- I know I'm right.
Everybody's fixated on
fucking 4,000 people,
while there's 7.7 billion people
who fucking worked, or
didn't, and then failed.
You want to be an actor,
get your ass to fucking LA.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- What do you mean, know how to start?
You don't know anybody?
Fucking, of course you know somebody.
Tweet and Instagram right now, be like,
"Who's in LA?"
You know who's in LA.
Your former teammate's fucking sister.
Your fucking friend from
high school's uncle.
People in LA, you know
fucking 30 people in LA.
You haven't fucking asked.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- I know.
- [Caller] Yeah, I guess.
Yeah, you're right dude.
- I know I'm right dude,
and I want it for you.
- [Caller] I appreciate that--
- And the best part is,
you might suck shit at acting,
but you need to find that out.
- [Caller] Yeah.
- Get your fucking North
Carolina ass to LA.
- [Caller] I will--
- Take Ashley with you,
and fucking go, live your fucking life,
don't fucking buy in to
an antiquated process.
You can act tomorrow.
- [Caller] You're right.
- I know I'm right.
Now are you scared to find
out that you suck at acting?
That's a different mental game.
- [Caller] Well, I feel like
I want to be mentally prepared for it.
One, I don't think I would suck,
and that's kinda maybe where the school
would kinda come into play,
but, I mean I just know
that for a few years now
I've just been so interested
in just the way movies work--
- My man.
I'm ending with this 'cause I gotta go.
Scratch that itch.
Scratch that itch that you're interested,
'cause you don't wanna
live with regret one day
and say, "Fuck, when I was 20,
"I wanted to know if I was an actor
"and I ended up not being an actor
"because the military
took me a different route
"and I ended up this,"
like go scratch that itch.
This is exactly when you can afford
to be high risk 'cause you're young enough
that you can fucking eat
Sonic burgers all day long.
And like fucking like roman,
romain, or whatever the fuck,
what's that shit called?
Roman noodles.
Ramen, like fucking,
this is when you do it.
And by the way, I'm gonna
save this live stream,
I'm gonna end it right now,
I'm gonna post it,
you can re-watch it,
and fucking 50 people invited you
to crash on their couch
during this stream.
- [Caller] Wow dude.
- So re-watch it,
click on their fucking Instagram handle,
DM, and be like, "I'm coming."
Dude, you need to be in yes culture,
not in over-thinking-all-the-variable
culture.
- [Caller] Yeah.
Wow dude.
- Perspective.
- [Caller] It really is, man.
- Most people do a ton of shit
to protect themselves from
ever finding out their truth.
(air whooshing)
- [Caller] So I just
gotta go find my truth.
- 100%.
You're putting fucking school,
and then army, and then school again,
on a pedestal,
all to not allow yourself
to find your truth.
- [Caller] You're right.
- I know man, failure
is what scares people.
(chilled music)
- [Caller] That's true.
- Get un-scared my man.
- [Caller] All right man.
- All right man.
- I appreciate you.
- See ya, love you, see ya.
- [Caller] Thank you,
bye, bye.
- Bye-bye.